One of the,
junior nurses said to me,
I used to have a pocket
full of papers, and I used to have to,
before the end of my shift,
I’d look at all my bits of paper
to make sure I've done everything.
Now, with the Federated Data
Platform, it's all in the system,
so she doesn't have to worry about it.
And she says it makes a difference
because she would quite often go home,
sit in the car, in the car park and think,
oh gosh, I've forgotten about Mrs.
or whatever, and she would run back
in or she’d phone somebody
that again shows you the level of care
that our staff have
for their patients.
A lot of clinicians in their day to day
roles, when you speak to them,
they're logging into
7, 8 different systems
just to complete
one patient transfer
Spreadsheets, bits of paper, email trails,
you know, the logistics of care.
That’s how I think about it
has many steps and many handovers.
There are a number of logistics activities
that need to happen and come together
in order for you to be released
from the hospital.
You've got all this data,
all in different shapes,
and we want to bring it together
so that you can see everything
in one view.
That basically means we're connecting
and liberating data
from siloed systems
into a single repository.
Now the opportunity on the
back of that is phenomenal.
So the NHS Federated Data Platform
is software
that enables us to connect together
lots of our local organisational systems,
the asset management system, your
workforce system, your patient system.
It allows us to connect all those together
so that we can use that information
in operational workflows.
What we designed in the FDP was we created
segregated instances, which every NHS
organisation owns for themselves,
but underpinned by what we refer to
as the Canonical Data Model, the CDM.
The CDM is consistent across
every instance that we deploy.
Data should not have to leave
a sovereign organisation.
It can be called and queried upon
need rather than it needs to move
every single time.
Foundry as a tool that underpins
the Federated Data Platform, provides
this unique capability of
Purpose-based Access Controls.
So the data that you have
is only for the use
that it's already been permitted for.
This is from my perspective,
is pretty unique to the Foundry tool.
And I've been absolutely blown away
by this capability.
So we spend a lot of time on-site, meeting
with real operational teams, frontline
clinicians, and trying to experience
those problems firsthand.
Working Palantir is fantastic
because you've got very young, dedicated
kind of
guys that just want to get on
with doing things.
They are very happy to have a go
and iterate.
Largely for me,
Palantir has been really good in that,
they've kind of
given me a lot of responsibility
and a lot of autonomy
and put me on a problem actually,
I cared quite a lot about.
It's been fantastic
working with Palantir as a partner.
We are at the table together,
working with our local organisations,
thinking about innovative solutions
to the biggest challenges
that the NHS is facing today
and the tenacity,
the skills that the Palantir engineers
bring is phenomenal.
We were able to build
the first Theatre Scheduling product
in a matter of weeks.
From ideation to and concept to product was done
I think in about three weeks.
And we were testing
with one clinician at the hospital
and a theatre manager.
It was demonstrating activities
which previously took over
four minutes to do,
to be done in 30 seconds.
We were able to look at individual
cases of patients who had had appointments
cancelled at one trust,
and they've been transferred over
to another trust
and were able to be seen sooner.
I think on average, people
being seen about 40 days sooner,
some up to two, three months sooner,
which is incredible.
And this is people
just going 20 minutes down the road
to a different hospital
who has more capacity.
Every hospital
that uses our Inpatient product
generally sees over 120 extra procedures
per month, per trust that uses it.
We've already delivered over 80,000
extra procedures
since the rollout of FDP.
That's 80,000 extra patients
been seen in existing NHS capacity.
What's been brilliant
is hearing the feedback
from our local organisations.
So we have maybe anaesthetist
in a hospital that say it's
normally really difficult for me
to understand what my schedule looks like.
And actually with the FDP
I can log in myself.
I know my patient list and “game
changing” is one of the phrases
that I hear the most.
One of our matron
said, you've changed my life.
It's just so much easier.
I can log into one system,
I can access the information I need,
and I can discharge my patients on time.
People like me do this job for a reason,
right?
It's for public value.
And sometimes you come across things
that really melt your heart.
It really gets to you.
The consultant, cancer consultant
that we were working
on, on the Cancer Waiting List tool.
What she said to me was,
since using the Federated Data Platform,
she's been able to space her day out
in a way that means that she can spread
good news amongst the bad news
that she has to give to patients.
Now, that seems quite a small thing,
but if you're giving bad news
all the time, it really means a lot.
And so to me, the FDP provides
an opportunity
for us to actually systematically solve
some of those bigger problems
in a way
that isn't just limited to a trust,
but it's actually kind of like scalable
and will actually make a larger difference
across the whole NHS.
The skills that the Palantir engineers bring to
the NHS FDP programme are phenomenal.
Their technical capabilities,
their engineering capabilities,
their business acumen and their ability
to work with our local organisations
and really understand
what those challenges are, is fantastic.
And that means that when we're presented
with the biggest challenges
that the NHS faces today,
having a Palantir engineer working side
by side with those in partnership
means that we know
that we'll come up with a solution
that means that we can deliver
better patient outcomes and services.
So we have a lot of staff that burn out
because of the extraordinary, tasks
that they have to do
and the amount
of bureaucracy in the system.
So being able to help deliver
a tool like the Federated
Data Platform is immensely helpful.
And for me, that's kind of
worth all its weight in gold.